quaithe also known as gwaith of the
shadow appeared in the second season in
only a few scenes and it was more than
enough to realize that she has some
special capabilities some sort of
supernatural abilities
she appeared a bit more in the books and
there she also seems to build magical
powers of prophesying clairvoyance which
she prodded her knowledge about Jura
being a former spy for King Robert with
her knowledge about the resumed Dark
Souls and Piatt priest EFT ordinances
Jagan's you want to placed a mother of
dragons
where are the Dragons will you betray
her again Jorah the Andal will you
betray her again never the thief you
seek is with her now
just like masanjia Quaithe is also
shadow binder capable of manipulating
sheriff's to their will
Cuevas described as a woman with wet and
shiny eyes wears a dark red lacquered
wooden mask
when they need see squeeze in a vision
during a dancer dragon she describes the
mask as being made of starlight Quaife
appears today near multiple occasions
throughout the books and usually comes
to the professor warning to go no you
must journey south to reach the west you
must go east to go forward you must go
back and to touch the light you must
pass beneath the shadow Quay to Daenerys
in underworld squid says to go north and
reach the west he must journey south and
go east to go forward you must go back
and to touch the light you must pass
beneath the shadow interpretation of
this prophecy will be to reach Westeros
and achieve your goals you must follow
the stream southeast move forward by
revisiting the path of the Trekkie
to learn to fly dragon you must earn his
trust all of which came true Quade
through prophecies also Mors Danny about
her events that are to come the glass
candles are burning soon comes the pale
mare and after her the others cracking
in dark flame lion Griffon the Sun Sun
and the mummer's dragon just none of
them remember the undying
beware the perfumed seneschal crave the
dares the pale mare is another name from
the bloody flux disease shortly after
the prophecy disease begins sickening
and killing people inside and outside
marine the other suggests that the
figures mentioned next are just as
dangerous
cracking his Greyjoy that is on his way
to marine dark flame is the priest of
her Laurel succumbing to marine lioness
Tyrion Lannister on his way to marine at
the time of the prophecy Griffin in the
books is Jon connington also known as
Griff at a time he wasn't on his way to
marine but Westeros presumably surely
counter him at one point the son son is
the son of Prince of Dorne who's on his
way to marine at the time of the
prophecy the mummer's dragon is Aegon
and
just the tagging is not true Targaryen
since mummers is an actor
all of these people represent a
potential danger for Danny so quaithe
warns her about them unlike no Sandra
Kwai doesn't interpret the prophecy
herself but rather lets they need to
decide what does it mean and what she
should do about it still there's very
little known about Quaithe other than
the fact that she seems to be deeply
invested in Danny for no apparent reason
so who truly squeezed and what does she
want according to some fans squid is a
shard a labia shardene was the beautiful
sister of Sir Arthur Dayne the sword of
the morning like way the share is
shrouded in mystery although she's
mentioned a lot in Song of Ice and Fire
and the noether george RR martin
mentioned someone as much as he mentions
a shara they'll probably have a big part
to play in the story to come a char was
present at the greater need Harrenhal
which set the stage for Game of Thrones
there she met Ned then they according to
many characters fell in love according
to the entire day and family assure Ned
Stark truly did fall in love at
Harrenhal lady Illyria Dana chars
younger sister believes this Lord a
Judean also known as Ned the current
Lord of star foolish our Illyria
instructors nephews to believe this in
storm sword see tells re about his
family about how his aunt azshara
committed suicide over her broken heart
hit a hesitantly tell Zahra that his
aunt Illyria told him that the Shirin
inert fell in love at the great tourney
at Harrenhal
educate surprise that tether never spoke
of her in the dance the Dragons through
barsen someone who remembers the greater
need her whole on quoting even after all
these years serve arson could still
recall a sharp smile the sound of her
laughter he had only to close his eyes
to see her with her long hair tumbling
about her shoulders and those haunting
purple eyes Lanier says the same eyes
sometimes when the Queen looked at him
he felt as he were looking at the chars
daughter but a shark's daughter had been
stillborn and his fair lady had thrown
herself from a tower soon after met with
grief for the shell she had lost and
perhaps for the man who had dishonored
her at Harrenhal as well she died never
knowing that sir burst and had loved her
how could she he was a knight of the
Kingsguard sworn to celibacy no good
could have come from telling her his
feelings no good came from silence as
well if I had a horse Rhaegar and Crown
- our queen of love and beauty why she
have looked at me instead of stark
Merson says she was honoured by a stark
but his version is biased due to the
feelings he had for her but carving
gives us more neutral take when talking
to Arya harvin is a member of the house
guard of Lord Eddard Stark at Winterfell
and he did give us a better insight
regarding the relationship between Ned
in the shower
lady ashara dayne it's an old tale that
one I heard it was some interval when I
was an older than your now I doubt
there's any truth to it but if there is
what of it when Ned met this Dornish
lady assure his brother Brandon was
still alive and it was him engaged to
lady Catelyn so there's no stain on your
father's honor there's not like a
tourney to make the blood run hot so
maybe some words were whispered in the
tent of a knight who can say words or
kisses maybe more but first the harming
that spring had come or so they thought
and neither of them was pledged carving
Tory stark beside the sharding herself
house Dayne in general is shrouded in
mystery one of the oldest houses in
Westeros house day in Seville is a sword
in the falling star it see the star fall
when Quetta Sharda nor House dinner
mentioned in A Song of Ice and Fire
there's usually reference to the Stars
this is why many people believe there's
a connection between Quaithe and the
danes of star fall the near Sun couple
of occasions instead of saying that she
hears squid she says she hears the
whispering of stars or is another quote
says the starts whispered in a woman's
voice the stars whispering could be the
reference the Danes as their sigil is a
sword in the falling star speaking of a
falling star shardene is said to have
thrown herself from a tower on a cliff
in star fall making her a falling star
but why would the shard these guys ask
waved full of the nearest and tried to
warn her about the upcoming events there
are two theories one is that a shard is
actually then Israel matter and Ned
Stark is her fighter a few days ago I
made a full video regarding this theory
but in case you missed it let's point
out the most important in schools and
evidence supporting this theory we know
that the Shara shared a denser net
awesome claim that they also fell in
love and shared a night together we also
know that the char was Esther burst on
calls I dishonored by a stark at
Harrenhal and we know that the char
shortly after give birth to a daughter
and lastly it's been pointed out
numerous times have the in resembles a
char a lot as already said I made a full
video regarding these theories if you'd
like to hear more evidence supporting it
feel free to check out my recent videos
another theory says that the shark net
don't necessarily need to be Denny's
parents it says the la Mer happened then
we think when that visited starpha after
the Tower of joy that let know about the
prophecy of the princess promised and
the fact that Ned knew the winter is
coming so NAT explained this to the
Danes were also very important in
prophecy the evidence for the Danes
being important to the prophecy in the
story in general is not only in Georgia
are Marsh
stamens that confirm it but it's simply
in their legendary sword as well the
sort of house Danis called dawn and the
person who is ready to build it receives
the title the sword of the morning
now let's hear those words again dawn
and the sword of the morning the great
horse here but after the long night
comes dawn in the morning I know that we
all believe everything has to be
complicated in Game of Thrones but
sometimes things are actually quite
simple and airplane for all of us to see
anyways as the theory goes Ned and the
Danes agree that the share would watch
ordinary sang get here on the right way
beside house Danes ancestral sword most
likely having in point role in the great
war Georgia Marne confirm himself an
important role the insert yet to have in
the story the Danes are still going to
play an important role in the future
george RR martin stated this leads us to
another George armors confirmation
regarding the dates you'll see more
Danes in future books that's all I can
say this could determine that we will
learn more the Danes that are already
introduced in story or we will see more
new characters could it be that there
are Danes that we already know of but
are not aware of them being veins
what's also point out the fact that
george RR martin confirmed himself
George has worked out a whole family
tree for house Dayne and it will be
published in the future books
this means that something huge is coming
as only the Great Houses get family
trees worked out the fact that George
Armand is waiting for the right time to
publish this one means that it will
likely be a huge twist regarding the
Dane family could Ned Stark and Daenerys
be placed in this family tree let me
know your opinion about this in the
comment section down below now that
you've been introduced to a theory in
which Quaithe is actually a sure Dane
let's take a look on a fear in which
quaithe is shir a sister she's one of
the infamous great bastards of King
Aegon the unworthy Targaryen she a
sister's name means star of the sea and
she said to have been the most beautiful
woman of the Seven Kingdoms so beautiful
that men across the realm fought to
death for her love now succeeded
including her brothers Brian and blood
rain rivers and Egger bitter still
rivers who fought on opposing sides
during the Blackfyre rebellion
Shira never married but took many lovers
and numerous duels were fought for her
favor her her brother Bloodraven was her
most eager suitor and repeatedly
proposed marriage to her although she
refused to marry him Shira did share her
bed with him her mother her brother
Aegon rivers known as better still also
desired her which only served to
increase the hatred between Bloodraven
and bittersteel there were rumors that
she really saw three to eight Bloodraven
when he served as hand of the king and
master whispers to King Aerys the
star garyun shira's faithfuls never
mentioned in the books Shir since there
was also reputed to share her mother's
skill in the dark arts to retain her
youth and beauty one of the reasons
people believe queef is actually share
is because shira's name means star of
the sea in comparison quits what a mask
is said to shine like starlight when
Daenerys has a vision under the track is
see the fact that she rose surname is
sister is another clue sailors use the
follow of a star called the stella maris
which means star of the sea when the
nurse is on the track is sea she asked
with faith once and quit responds with
to show you the way
quit wants to guide the nearest along
her journey under the track is see like
the stella maris shares namesake guide
sailors on the actual sea the third
theory regarding quoits true identity is
her being denise herself theory states
that then is actually a time traveler
who goes back to warn herself in
disguise
it's pretty much based on the fact that
we don't know much of Quaithe other than
the fact that she seems to be deeply
invested in the nares for no apparent
reason
think about it when Danny rising Qarth
quit immediately knows about dangers
awaiting her dare and warns her and then
he tells her to liberate Quaithe
cryptically response to go north moscow
south to reach the west you must go east
to go forward you must go back and to
touch the light you must pass beneath
the shadow through the prophecy she
basically tells her how to reach her
goals the theory also realized the fact
that quaithe hides her face while other
shadow binders like Melisandre for
example doesn't there's the reason she
hides her face and according to this
theory it's because it's the nurse
herself
long story short quafe is arguably the
most mysterious character in Game of
Thrones and hopefully we'll get to know
her true identity before the show is
over or she could just be quit of the
shadow and nothing more
in my opinion quit being a shard Dane is
more likely than her being shear sister
Daenerys or self the constant references
to stars to equate a shared Dane or
House dinner mentioned in Song of Ice
and Fire is the biggest key here and
from George are Marne we know the Danes
have a huge part to play in the story